move over idris elba there's a new black
star in town he's called taharka
eikan-do and as everyone knows I can
there's a common Nigerian name this is
he
no no that's Larry a condo a condo I
mean the actor no that's the curator and
cultural strategist a shara I can dare I
know we all look the same to you but for
heaven's sake
thank you yes that's the brother who got
a hundred thousand pound grant
specifically set aside to encourage
black artists ok taharka doesn't look
very Nigerian maybe that's because his
parents were Irish as were their parents
in fact as far as Antony Lennon as he
was christened knows none of his
ancestors ever set foot off the Emerald
Isle but Anthony says his Mediterranean
complexion and experiences growing up
qualify him to be a born-again African
hmm
there aren't that many advantages to
being dark-skinned I can tell you so I
think it's a bit of a cheek for Antony
to change his identity and benefit from
a bob or to my own family count at least
one Celtic ancestor but I don't think
I'll be sticking the white Brit box any
time soon this isn't just a race thing
some people saying that men should be
able to choose to be women willy-nilly
as it were well I think that if you want
to go into the women's changing rooms
you need to leave your wedding tackle at
the door if you want disability benefits
you have to prove you need them and if
you want to be black a quick session in
the local tanning partner parlor won't
cut it be proud of what and who you are
but don't trivialize vital issues by
becoming an identity fraud stir
thank you for choosing this topic Trevor
it's I've been having discussions with
my friends about this all week talking
about it I think that for me I think
it's a bit different from gender because
the difference between rates and genders
I know you know is that discussions
about gender actually involve questions
of biology
whereas race is a social construct you
can't do a test and it's something that
we we've all been socialized into and I
thought for me the problem with this is
that I think it comes from a
misunderstanding of what it means to be
black and I think that misunderstanding
comes from the fact that we live in a
society that is very hostile often
towards people of color and many people
of color have had throughout their life
living in this society that experience
of racism but I think what Anthony Lenin
has done is misunderstand what it means
to be black as just the experience of
having experienced racism and you know
for me that's what he's saying because
he's saying I've experienced racism
because people think I'm black therefore
I'm black therefore I can self identify
his black and tap into funding for black
actors and for me that is a real
misunderstanding of what it means to be
black that's kind of diminishing our
black identities into the fact that
you've experienced racism and I can kind
of see how that happened but I think
it's really important to push back
against it I think the sad thing about
this story is he's clearly somebody who
wants to be an ally to black theatre and
black arts that's great there are lots
of people who are allies in that way
it's just not necessary to take the
extra step of trying to change yourself
as you said into something you're not
and that sadly undermines but the whole
project of my one thing to be an ally in
the class plane I'm with you except at
one point I mean actually we say races
are not biological actually gender you
know they're bits that associated with
gender and frankly with race there's
something that associated with with my
race and it's all over me okay but I
think the more important point here is I
I don't really want to have a go at
Anthony or Takako whatever he's called
what I really really want to poke at
here is the credulity of the authorities
who are so afraid of somebody going oh
but they will put up with all
of nonsense which in the end redound to
the disadvantage of people of color or
in okay I just wanna just before we hand
over to us I just want to read you some
tweets which I think sum up the matter
quite vividly this is from Coco Khan at
the Guardian of course that paper
who says Anthony at and IO Lenin is the
epitome of white entitlement to be at
the center of everything to have access
to every word every culture every
community that's not being an ally
especially when it might end up
destabilizing pame arts funding and some
things ain't yours fam okay I agree you
I think this was a daft decision by an
organization to say because you think
you're black we're deeming you black in
there I just think it was ridiculous and
you're right there is an issue in you
know I came out of television and out of
theater and the rest of it there is an
issue about overwhelmingly white
organizations and if you look at the
author of the famous hideously white I
will he I was deal it was interesting
cousin of the day I want the day after
that famous hideously white phase I got
a phone call from Lenny Henry who just
said you're dead right well you know
this needs to be done which leads me
into a quote from Lenny Henry two
figures as they stand in our industry
are still appalling Blamey employment in
film in this country is three percent so
three percent of the people that work on
films and television in this country are
black Asian minority ethnic you know
when you consider that places like
London for instance is 40 percent be AME
that's a really lopsided figure yeah but
aunty Glenn and I must be I want to be
fair to him because that's the kind of
guy I am
he says his defense of this is some
people call themselves born-again
Christian some people call me a
born-again African don't like that he
said I prefer to call myself an African
born-again good to say he says although
I'm white with white parents I've gone
through the struggles of a black man a
black actor I don't think so many
don't think so pretending to be black so
he could get money he believes this
stuff yes he's going in the wreck saying
I am white my parents are white my I see
myself whether it's the arts council
awarded grants on merit not on people's
ethnicity isn't that a far simpler way
of doing it doesn't work that way you've
got a look at areas where you say hang
on there's something wrong here
it's not that's where you use public
money three percent of an industry
that's back no it's not it's not a
Muslim operating on merit so to correct
it how do you think I was chairman of
the film institute with further and we
but the interesting thing was we did I
mean we had the usual race relations
policy that came up to us you know which
was other and we threw it out and said
that's no good we fund through lottery
money we fund a lot of films in this
country therefore we're going to start
requiring you to demonstrate that you
have taken into account the differences
and if you want public money then you've
got to have more black people and more I
think I think I know it is working on me
in film now that was probably three
years ago it will probably take it take
a generation generation but it but but
you don't get the money for your film
unless you can demonstrate you're doing
something I've got a couple of right of
responses I just quickly want to get in
this is from the to LA to la rúa theater
company they say we've been at the
forefront of the celebration and
development of black British theatre and
theatre makers since 1986 Antony econd
Deo
Leninist allama Theatre Company's
associate director as an artist of mixed
heritage he's not only eligible for the
position but his experience work and
achievements make him an exceptional
person for the role and then the Arts
Council England says till our raised
their wish to support Antony with us in
responding we took into account the law
in relation to race and ethnicity this
is a very unusual case we do not think
it undermines the support we provide to
black and minority ethnic people within
the theatre sector summing up in a
sentence
Trevor
you're right but as we live in a time
now it symptomatically age where you can
just choose whether it's they are a
great company but I just can't
understand why they would describe him
as someone with mixed heritage when he's
not and because that's the world in
which we live it said do this I mean can
I just make this there is a you know we
can laugh about this there is a serious
point which actually slightly comes
through one of the things you said Carol
the problem that we've got in a moment
is we have to understand where there are
disadvantages in our society and you've
got to assess that on an objective basis
so we know what the gender pay gap is we
know what the ethnic pay gap is if you
cannot define people on some sort of
objective basis and they just decide on
Thursday I'm black on Friday my wife
Tamara you will never know you would
never know what the pay gap is in your
industry I would never know what having
the fund specifically for being a ma
people it's wholly too seriously
lots of organizations have recognized
where there are groups in society or
disadvantaged
you have got to give them some help yeah
but it is wrong that I can decide today
that I myself identifying as a woman
trying bright panties at Dorothy Perkins
the audience just left